and green playing the rover off of Rondo
defensive schemes are similar Mike as
Davis makes the three petite big shots
name on Rondo hit three three-pointers
in Game two Hill left open he'll Rosten
Rondo Tamara touch Meritage up when I'm
the facts at home
one of the premier two-way players in
the league
Mike he almost had his career like in
defeat merits its quick move against
Livingston excellent defensive limit
Spencer Davis right there I'm a follower
I thank you Lisa please keep an eye on
that more throws it up to Davis back to
Rondo shot clock at five merit it's
quick hats for the pass inside beautiful
entry greenly talented pastors and good
finished by winning bank century again
Davis shot clock and game clock Rondo
Knights inside beautiful pink pass Alvin
Gentry's was the associate head coaches
Moore's layup is good and a foul holiday
is also a terrific passer as Davis
knocks down another he's got 29 instead
of the backing off and letting him on
his own times make decision Davis
33 port takes the three after Davis
Davis off the dribble and throws it down
exclamation point for Anthony Davis